okay welcome very excited to be here
this is my first Pike on Israel and
welcome to pandas for fun and profit so
let's start with a question how many of
you let's say in the past year how many
of you have had to make a decision about
what to do with your money raise your
hand quite a number of people okay next
question
how many of you use data science and
data and math to figure out what to do
with your money yeah a little bit less
so that's what we're going to talk about
today but the gist is this is really
about pandas it this is a beginner class
or a beginner talk the basics of pandas
by way of example using an example that
I think you might find interesting that
I found interesting looking at a little
bit about stock investing so what is
pandas pandas is a python-based data
analysis toolkit provides high
performance data store data structures
and data analysis tools it's built on
top of numpy so it takes advantage of
some of the things that numpy has and it
also uses matplotlib under the hood for
visualization so here's the back story I
only started using Python about seven or
eight months ago a few months ago I
heard about pandas I got very excited it
sounded interesting
I took a three-hour online workshop
about pandas from Matt Harrison and I
said to myself wow this is really cool I
want to learn more about pandas maybe I
can use this to test some ideas that I
have in the marketplace so I decided to
take this project that I had in mind and
just do it in panda so that I could
learn more so a little bit about me I'm
an engineer at Bloomberg I spent most of
my career doing C and C++ on the server
side I was a member of the Chartered
Financial Analysts Institute for 10
years and I started my career a long
time ago in biophysics a little bit
about Bloomberg we provide all of these
services to several hundred thousand
financial market professionals and we
also provide to the public
financial news via television radio and
online we have about 20,000 employees in
167 locations worldwide including Tel
Aviv and Jerusalem
we have over 5,500 software engineers
and more than 2,000 of them are involved
with Python
so in conclusion actually I just decided
that to do something different in this
talk I'm going to give my conclusions at
the beginning so you'll have what to
think about as I go through the talk so
the conclusions our panthis makes it
easy to explore your data to shape your
data to analyze it and visualize it
however as powerful as panthis is it's
important to know your domain have some
domain knowledge you don't necessarily
have to be an expert you have to have
some domain knowledge about your data
and you should also plan to spend fifty
percent or more of your time shaping
your data that is getting it into the
data structures that are most suitable
for the analysis that you want to do and
therefore about 50% of this talk or more
will be about shaping the data so let's
talk about stock ownership when you buy
a stock you actually own part of the
company and what's a company a company
is nothing more than a group of people
working together to earn money and
earning money has value so for that
reason a lot of people look at what's
called the price earnings ratio that's
the price of the stock divided by the
earnings of the company and there's a
concept that if the price earnings ratio
of one stock is less than that of
another stock then the stock that has
the smaller price earnings ratio you're
getting more for your money that stock
is said to be under price so before we
can test this hypothesis that a low p/e
is actually under price or a bargain
let's talk about pandas so there's three
primary data structures to understand
Pama pandas there's the index more multi
index series and a data frame an index
is nothing more than a list of keys that
point to data it's essentially a hash
table you can think of it as a Python
dictionary a series is the data combined
with the index
you have a list of data and you have the
index keys pointing to that data here's
an example of a series we have the
values here here's the index in this
case the index is our date objects the
index name the name of the series and
the data type of the series those are
the basics parts of a series object so
what can you do with the series you can
take the Len of the series see how much
data you have in there you can access
the data either by key or by position
here's an example of accessing the data
by key we put in a certain date we get
back the data for that date or by
position so let's talk about a data
frame your data frame is the
2-dimensional spreadsheet you have your
rows and your columns each column is a
pamda series and each row is a panda
series here's the parts of the data
frame we have the same things the values
the index the index name and now we have
columns notice if we take a look at the
index attribute on the data frame we see
an index object which contains the list
of keys the columns attribute is also an
index object this is important to
understands the both of columns and your
index our index objects this hash table
that points to the data the only thing
is we on the horizontal axis we call it
columns on the vertical Alex as we call
it index but the both indexes so here's
some things you can do within index you
can take the shape see how many rows and
columns you have again you can access
the data by key however in this case
since we have two indexes you can do
both rows and columns in your key to get
a particular data element you can also
use just a row or just a column here's
an example of using just a row so when I
pull out a row as I said before a row is
the data is a Panda series notice that
when I pull out the row and I get a
series the index on the series are
actually the column indexes on the data
frame and the name of the series is the
key for that row there was
to the series here's a multi index a
multi index basically you have multiple
levels of indices you have a level zero
index and those keys point to a level
one index you can have more than that in
this case we actually have three
dimensions because we have two indices
on the columns and one index on the
vertical axis you can have as many in as
many indices as many levels as you want
so that you can basically express in two
dimensions as many I'm yeah express in
two dimension as many dimensions as you
want alright so now we know the basics
of pandas so now we can test our
hypothesis which was that loci
represents a bargain and if so in buying
stocks with a low p/e should result in
high returns so we have to somehow
compare the p/e to returns and we want
to see a negative correlation we want to
see when the p/e goes down the returns
go up so this is this is the fine print
as this information not advice yadda
yadda yadda okay so we need a data set
to test this I chose for my dataset the
30 stocks in the Dow Jones Industrial
Average I would have much preferred a
much larger data set the S&P 500 of
Russell 5000 however this was my first
time using pandas I wanted something
small that I could actually scroll
around the data frame and see all the
data to understand what's going on we're
going to need the price and the earning
price earnings ratio for these stocks
and we're also going to need to
calculate the return which means we need
the prices and the dividends for these
stocks so I got myself a CSV file the
price earnings ratios it's kind of ugly
but pandas has a very handy read CSV
method which you can call giving it the
filename and it takes that CSV file and
it puts it into a data frame now notice
when you read it plain it simply creates
an index and column headings that are
numeric but now you can look around the
data frame and see what you've got you
can see here in the upper left-hand
corner we have the start and end date
for the entire data set we have a lot of
Nan's where there was no data in the
third row I can see with the ticker
symbols for the stocks and in the first
column I can see the dates I can
you also that rows 4 and 5 are just
telling me the field that I requested
the price earnings ratio so I don't need
that so I can call read CSV again and
now I can specify the header row is Row
3 index column become 0 or par state
equals true means if you see something
that looks and smells like a date turn
it into a date object and I'm telling it
to skipper as 4 in 5 now I have a better
looking data frame I have my ticker
symbols as the column headings dates
along the index but I'm still not happy
with this because I don't want to have
to type in this whole long string for
each ticker every time I want to access
a column by date all I really care about
this is the ticker itself I don't need
to know this these two letter codes are
the primary exchange primary exchange
that the stock trades on and the word
equity just tells me that it's a stock
so if I look at the index I see it's
just list of strings I can use a list
comprehension and split out the first
token and then I have a better looking
data frame where now I can access the
data frame simply by the ticker symbol
over the stock and the columns and the
dates on one side notice however that I
have a lot of missing data back in 1989
some of these stocks didn't exist then
everyone trading back on or they didn't
have earnings to report a price earning
ratio I also have 31 columns what's
going on here I got 30 stocks from the
Dow Jones Industrials so again I was
able to look through my data frame and I
discovered that I had an extra column it
was the index itself the Dow Jones
Industrial Index
fortunately data frame has a handy
method called drop where I can tell it
to drop any number of columns or rows so
here I'm telling it to drop the column
that includes the Dow Jones Industrial
Index and now I'm down to the 30 stocks
this is just me again exploring the data
panthous allows you to explore your data
and I personally like to do that a lot
before I do analysis poke around see
what it looks like so here I'm looking
at the end of the data frame and I see I
have a lot of data there and looking
through the data frame I noticed that
most of the missing data was in the
older dates the shape of the data frame
was 360 by 30 that's 30 years of monthly
data I don't really need that much so I
decided to take the last hundred and
forty-four points the last twelve years
of data
and now I have data beginning in 2007
and there are no missing points at least
as far as I can see there so now the
data this is just me again exploring the
data the shape is 144 two rows I checked
the type of some of the cells to make
sure that the types were converted read
CSV will attempt to convert it to the
proper type but if there's any stray
characters in your CSV file it might
leave everything as strings and there
are methods where you can convert it
manually yourself after cleaning up the
stray characters so let's describe the
data frame data frame has a method
called describe which goes through
column by column and gives you the count
the average and standard deviation min
and Max and the various quartiles of the
data it's another way to look at your
data see what's going on and each of
those attributes also has a method of
its own here I'm calling count and it
gives me back a series which contains
the count for every column and then I
noticed that one of the columns only has
22 five data points I can compare the
series count with the scalar 144 and I
get back a boolean series which tells me
true or false
whether or not the count is less than
144 and now here's the nice thing I can
then take that pooling a series and
filter out the columns that have less
than 144 data points that gives me a
list of three stocks that had less than
144 data points and I can call drop on
that and get rid of those stocks so now
I'm down to 27 stocks but at least I
know I have data for everything so I'm
not gonna worry how that's going to
affect my analysis so taking a look at
the mean you can call me and get a
series and the nice thing about every
series and every data frame is that it
has a method called plot so that you can
plot the elements of the series in the
day frame if I plot the mean I get a
nice colorful graph with the stocks
along the bottom everything looks good
there's nothing really standing out a
whole lot there's a couple of stocks
that are kind of high they're a little
more expensive but if they look at the
standard deviation whoa there's one
stock there that's standing out way more
than the others so I wanted to see what
was going on with this stock
I plotted the p/e ratio over time for
that sock and I see back in 2017 this
stocks p/e ratio shot through the roof
now what can happen when companies
report their earnings typically
quarterly and occasionally they have a
loss and the report negative earnings
that's not what's happening here
because if they do report negative
earnings then we don't calculate a p/e
ratio but sometimes they have a loss and
but they end up reporting very slightly
positive entering earnings maybe a few
cents and if that happens and the stock
price was already high the p/e ratio is
going to go through the loop through the
roof so I decided to drop this stock
just so wouldn't affect the analysis I
can always add it back later and see how
it how it does affect the analysis now
we'll look at the standard deviation
everything looks good no one's really
standing out all that much so how are we
going to define a low p/e I've kind of
been implying that what really matters
is the PU in relation to in relation to
the other stocks so I'm going to say
that I want to look at the number of
standard deviations that the p/e of the
given stock is below the market average
and that's what we call the z-score so I
grab the mean and the standard deviation
I put them into a data frame of
themselves because I'm going to need
those to calculate the z-score and I
plotted it again I'm going to explore my
data see what's going on it looks kind
of normal to me it's moving around the
standard deviation is less than the mean
that's good and now I can calculate the
z-score the data frame has methods
subtract divide add that sort of thing
so I can take this way I can do in a
single line of code I can do math on
every element in the entire data frame
so I'm subtracting the mean dividing by
the standard deviation that gives me the
z-score I see some of them are very
positive these are stocks whose PE is
very much above the average some are
negative they're below the average I
decided just to look at the max and min
of each stock just to take a look at
what it what it was if it seemed normal
or anything was standing out and I
plotted that so I have the max and min
p/e ratio for every stock everything
looked kind of okay to me here there was
nothing standing out that made me
worried so now we have a way to measure
whether the p/e is high or low
and we need to calculate returns so that
we can compare them formula for return
finding that final value divided by
starting value but if I want to compare
returns for different periods but as I
want three month returns six month
returns it's good to analyze the return
the other thing to know here is that the
final value requires but the final price
and the dividends that were earned
during the period of return that we're
calculating so I have a CSV file with
prices I read that in same issues as
before I cleaned it up a little bit this
also goes back to 1989 there's a couple
of stocks missing prices they weren't
trading yet so I want to get this this
data frame into the same shape as the
p/e ratio data frame now I could try to
remember which stocks I deleted and
which dates I deleted but a nice handy
dandy thing is that I can pull out the
start date and end date from the p/e
ratio data frame and I can use that to
slice the prices data frame and I can
also put the columns from the p/e data
frame to select out of the pricing data
frame and now I have the pricing data
frame the same shape as a p/e data frame
now what about dividends what shape
should the divins be it's always good to
figure out what shape what data
structure you want your data in before
you read it
the issue with dividends is that well
dividends are money paid to shareholders
and the data is sparse some stocks don't
even pay dividends they pay quarterly
sometimes they don't pay and what I
really need to do is I need to find the
dividends again during the period that
I'm calculating returns so I decided to
store my dividends as a dict where the
key is the ticker symbol and the value
is the series of dividends by date and
then I can grab the series as I'm
calculating return for each stock and go
in and slice by date those dividends
that contribute to the return so here is
my dividend CSV file it really looks
kind of ugly it turned out perusing the
file that this isn't actually the file
this is the data frame from the file
every stock had nine columns in this
file
I have the stock ticker symbol in one
column nothing else in that column a
date column and an amount column and the
other columns I don't need so I wrote a
I wrote a loop to go through the data
frame nine columns at a time and pull
out the stuff that I needed you can take
a look at this later I won't go through
the code now and I ended up with a
dictionary with the keys or the ticker
symbol and I can go in by each ticker
symbol and I get a series of the
dividends this is me just testing that
my idea works that I can key into the
dividend dictionary by stock and by date
range and then I can sum up the
dividends from that series and get the
total number of dividends that apply to
the return so now I want to calculate
the return for different periods of time
because I don't know which ones may or
may not correlate to the p/e ratio so
this means that for each data go to that
date and let's say a three month return
I go to the date three months later
that's my final price calculate the
dividends get the dividends from in
between they're added in to final price
calculate the return and then I move to
the next date and do the same thing so
there is no method to calculate returns
like there's a mean and standard
deviation on a data frame but there is a
method called apply which allows you to
apply any function that you write to the
data frame so I wrote a function to
calculate the returns the important
thing to note here is that it passes in
the columns because I'm going column by
column each time it calls my function it
passes in a column on prices and I can
grab the dividends and calculate them
that way so I called apply and now have
returns some are positive some are
negative this is an example of
three-month returns right here so how do
I know if the return is high and low
well just as before I want to compare it
to the marketplace so I want the z score
for each return sorry and then we'll
take the correlation between the z score
of the PE and the z score of the return
so here I just plotted it from one stock
again I'd like visualizing things so I
see down here for example in 2013 with
the z-scores going low the returns are
going higher
this stocks return is two to three
standard deviations above the market
looks kind of good to me
picture's worth a thousand words but
there's strength in numbers so let's
just calculate the correlations so the
series has a method called core where
you can pass in another series gives you
the correlation for that I wrote myself
a function that where I can pass in the
range of data points that I want here
I'm doing the entire 144 month
correlation and I correlated against all
five return periods that I calculated 26
stocks that's 130 returns and I found
that the mean correlation is negative
but only slightly so now I'm getting a
little nervous maybe my low p/e
investment strategy is not going to work
now this is a good thing this is the
whole point of this if you run the
numbers and it says it's not gonna work
save your money right it's telling you
that if it didn't work in the past it
mine is probably not gonna work in the
future
so I poked around on the data some more
I looked at some of the positive
correlations which is not what I was
hoping to see I also looked at some of
the negative correlations and I noticed
that in general those stocks that did
show negative correlations were
correlating with longer returns so much
for getting rich quick but there's an ID
here maybe I can invest in stocks that
have low p/e and show a negative
correlation so I have here's my test
plan I have three trading strategies one
is buy all the stocks that's basically
just investing in an index mutual fund
buy the stocks with poke low p/e that
was my original hypothesis or buy this
with low p/e that give a history of
negative correlation so we need a period
of time where we calculate the return
the correlation I'm sorry and we also
need a gap to calculate the return so
for example for the 2-year returns the
latest correlation that I can calculate
is two years before my trade date
otherwise I'm using prices in the future
of my trade date and if I could predict
the future this I wouldn't need this
whole analysis however once I set this
up I can then move forward in time and
do this for many different dates
so I ran this for every day from January
2014 to January 2017 that's 36 months
doing all three trading charities as if
I was buying the stock holding it for
two years and selling it each month so
this is just six of those months showing
you that the you can see here on some of
the months the negative correlation low
p/e strategy would did a lot worse than
the market and in some cases it did a
lot better than the market but if I take
all 36 months together I noticed that at
least for the case of two year and
three-year correlations I beat the
market by between two and almost four
percent now that's assuming that I have
enough money to invest every single
month in all those stocks but if I was
only going to invest once I could look
at those 36 months as 36 different
scenarios and if I look at it that way
then the low p/e case is about 50/50 if
half the time to beat the market half
the time not and the negative
correlation low p/e case beat the market
almost two thirds of the time and didn't
mean to beat the market about a third of
this one so in conclusion panthis makes
it easy to explore your data to shape
and analyze it you need to have some
domain knowledge and plan to spend fifty
percent or more of your time shaping
your data thank you question okay so the
question was how well does this work for
really large data sets I'm hoping it
works really well as I said I wanted to
do a large data set but it since this
was my first time using pandas I did
this small I literally just finished
this about 10 days ago so I'm hoping to
try a large data set next and maybe I
can post it somewhere and let you know
how it worked out okay thank you